let's say that you normally go to bed at
10 p.m and you wake up at 6 00 a.m but
tomorrow morning you've got an early
morning flight so you have to wake up at
4 00 a.m rather than 6 a.m how much
sleep have you lost well you've lost 2
hours of your 8 hour night of sleep so
you've lost 25
yes and no you've lost 25 of your total
sleep but based on the structure of
sleep that we just described you may
have lost 50 60 70 of all of your rem
sleep all of your dream sleep
so there are there are real implications
to understanding that
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
professor of neuroscience and psychology
at the university of california berkeley
director of the center for human sleep
science and host of the matt walker
podcast dr matthew walker welcome to the
reuben report
pleasure to be with you dave thanks for
having me well i'm thrilled that we're
doing this because as you know we're
airing this in august but right now it's
the last couple days of july i'm on my
30-day digital and really societal uh
and i'm going to work on a lot of things
diet exercise digital detox but also
work on some sleep stuff and that is
your area of expertise so i guess before
i ask you anything else how does one
become
curious and enamored and uh eventually
live their life to tell people about
sleep of all things
yeah i think
myself like many of my colleagues we are
all accidental sleep researchers you
know i don't think when we were kids and
you were going around the classroom and
the teacher was saying you know what
would you like to be when you grow up no
one was shooting up there and saying i'd
really love to be a sleep researcher so
um i fell into it by accident when i was
doing my phd i was studying different
types of dementia and trying to diagnose
them very early on
failing miserably and i realized i
should be measuring my patients when
they were asleep rather than when they
were awake to measure their brain wave
activity started doing that i got some
great results and realized that was 20
years ago realized that at the time no
one could answer a very simple question
why do we sleep
um and the best answer we had back then
was that we sleep to cure sleepiness
which is the the fat
you know that's like saying well you eat
to cure hunger no you eat for a whole
plethora of different reasons
now 20 years later due to the work of
all of my colleagues and we've done a
little bit too i hope
we've had to upend the question we've
had to ask is there any operation of
your brain and is there any
physiological system in your body that
isn't wonderfully hands enhanced when
you get sleep or demonstrably impaired
when you don't get enough and so far the
answer seems to be no
yeah all right well there's a whole
bunch of questions that i want to ask
you that are going to revolve sort of
around my sleep habits and my nap habits
and
this thing this thing what's in this
coffee cup but right now which you
probably can't guess i'm so glad that
you're drinking decaffeinated
i honestly don't think i've ever yeah i
don't think i've ever had decaf but
before we get into any of any of those
specifics uh can just talk to me sort of
broadly about sleep you know we hear
about sort of like you know the type of
sleep that you're happy having
throughout the night what's the most
important when are you getting the most
restorative stuff all that
yeah so sleep at least in human beings
and in fact in all mammalian species is
broadly separated into two types we have
non-rapid eye movement sleep and then we
have rapid eye movement sleep
and those two types of sleep will play
out in this beautiful sort of battle for
brain domination throughout the night
and then the cerebral war is going to be
won and lost between non-rem and rem
every 90 minutes and then it's just
going to be replayed every 90 minutes to
create your standard sort of dave rubin
sleep cycle
what's different however is the ratio of
non-rem to rem within those 90 minute
cycles as you move across the night so
what i mean by that is in the first half
of last night the majority of your
90-minute cycles were comprised of lots
of deep non-rem sleep and very little
rem sleep but as you push through to the
second half of the night that seesaw
balance actually shifts
and now the majority of those 90-minute
cycles is comprised much more of rem
sleep
and rem sleep is the stage that we
typically associate with dreaming
and i mentioned this sort of
architecture not just because it's
hopefully intellectually interesting but
it has implications so let's say that
you normally i'm just going to make this
up and we'll hopefully hear what your
actual sleep schedule is but
let's say that you normally go to bed at
10 p.m and you wake up at 6 00 a.m but
tomorrow morning you've got an early
morning flight so you have to wake up at
4 00 a.m rather than 6 a.m how much
sleep have you lost well you've lost 2
hours of your 8 hour night of sleep so
you've lost 25 percent
yes and no you've lost 25 of your total
sleep but based on the structure of
sleep that we just described you may
have lost 50 60 70 of all of your rem
sleep all of your dream sleep so there
are there are real implications to
understanding that to your point though
which one is more important
all stages of sleep are actually
important
different stages of sleep do different
things for your brain and your body at
different times of night but we need all
of them you know if when you think about
sleep as being such an idiotic thing to
do from an evolutionary perspective you
know if mother nature could have said
well i'm going to take these three
stages of sleep and i'm just going to
remove them so we save some time and
there's no harm to the organism then she
would have done it
hundreds millions of years ago
but all stages of sleep have been
preserved throughout the evolutionary
path that means all of them are
important and that's exactly what we're
finding so is eight hours is that the
magic number that everybody sort of
still seems to think is like you know
for the average person eight hours is
the number that you want to get
the rain there is a range so what we
recommend right now is somewhere between
seven to nine hours of sleep is what the
average adult seems to require
once you get below seven we can
typically start to measure impairments
in your brain and your body
and you know so much so based on the
evidence that the number of people who
seem to be able to survive on less than
six hours of sleep without showing any
impairment
rounded to a whole number and expressed
as a percent of the population is
actually zero
interesting so i'll give you a little
bit of my personal part of this on on
the eight hours um when i started
writing my first book last year or
really over two years ago at this point
when i first started writing it i would
find that i was thinking about it so
much that i would go to sleep let's say
somewhere between like 11 and 12 p.m
and or you know midnight basically i'd
be thinking and then i'd wake up early
with the same thoughts on my mind so i'd
wake up at like 6 00 a.m and then from 6
a.m
till literally like 3 p.m i could just
write and write and write right right
and then it would be like man i need a
break right now and i started taking
sort of 20 minute or half hour naps
around 3 p.m and i still try to do that
i can't always do it obviously but i try
to do that and i'm curious does the
if you can move some of it into a nap
later in the day do you need it
continuously
that's a beautiful question so
firstly there is some importance about
the continuity of sleep and what i mean
by that is at night for that six hours
that you were getting if it's very
choppy sleep it's very sort of staccato
and it's broken up and it's peppered
with lots of awakenings
that's not good quality sleep but let's
go back to your example or your lived
life which is you know six hours of
sleep and then a nap during the day is
that okay
i think the first thing to note is that
we human beings may not have been
designed in the way that most of us
sleep right now which is what we call
monophasic sleep in other words one long
single bout of sleep at night
because if i place electrodes on your
head
sometime between the sort of one to four
pm mark for most people there is a drop
in your brain's level
of alertness
which and it's it's pre-programmed it
has nothing to do with a big lunch by
the way some people think that but you
know in the afternoon in meetings you
can start to see those ugly head bobs
that sort of you know it's a dead
giveaway people are
the three o'clock feeling right didn't
uh just five-hour energy people made an
awful lot of money on this feeling they
certainly did indeed but it's it's
genetically hardwired as i said it's
pre-programmed it happens to all of us
what that means is that we may not have
been designed as a species to sleep in a
monophasic pattern we may have been
designed to sleep in what we call a
biphasic pattern which is a long bout of
sleep at night just as you're getting
and then a short sort of siesta-like nap
in the afternoon
um so i think that that's perfectly fine
in fact we may be designed to do that
but naps are a double-edged sword
they're a sword there is a dark side to
naps and it's the following
when you s sort of when you're awake
during the day you build up all of this
healthy sleepiness and it's a chemical
that builds up and it's been building up
in my brain and your brain since the
moment we woke up this morning and it's
called adenosine the more of it that
builds up the sleepier you feel and then
when you go to sleep at night the brain
gets the chance to evacuate all of that
sleep pressure all of that adenosine so
that after about eight hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and restored
the problem with naps then is that if
you take a nap that's too long or too
late in the afternoon or in the evening
it just takes the edge off that
sleepiness it's a little bit like um
a valve on a steam cooker you know it
just just releases some of that steam
and so now it's harder for you to fall
asleep and then stay asleep at night so
it's a little bit like snacking before
your main meal uh
so i think the you know for you i would
say if you are not struggling with sleep
at night and you can nap regularly
during the day the naps of about 20
minutes sort of sometime around
stop before about 4 p.m that's great but
if you are struggling with sleep at
night
then avoid naps during the day build up
all of that healthy sleepiness have you
done any research or do you know of
anyone that's done any research
sometimes what i'll find is if i try to
just close my eyes for 20 minutes at 3
o'clock i don't necessarily fall asleep
like and it's actually pretty rare that
i would get into a deep sleep but you
know i could be in that quasi-sleep
stage but sometimes it's more just i've
just closed my eyes and and just try not
to think about anything major politics
the craziness of the world and that in
and of itself is almost enough of a
reset have they done any research on
that that just the process of just 20
minutes with your eyes closed and maybe
just getting into that initial phase
could be enough
yeah we have done uh studies on that and
that's exactly what we're finding that
even that quiet rest where you have your
eyes closed and you're somewhat
disengaged now if you look at the brain
itself it's actually dipping like a
little beak into water it's dipping
itself and having a little soup son of
sort of sleep during that time most of
that time you're not aware that you're
asleep because it's still lighter stages
of sleep but it can be restorative it
can have benefits for your mood for your
emotions even some benefits for
cardiovascular health
is it as potent um as you know getting
into sleep no it's not but is it better
than just constantly trying to power
through and grab an another cup of
coffee and you know hope for the best
absolutely it's much better than that so
it's all a range i think there's a
gradient of different conscious states
that our brain goes through and some of
them can really be beneficial doesn't
have to all be about sleep all right so
you mentioned coffee i already showed
you the coffee cup i'm a coffee guy when
i wake up in the morning the first thing
that i think about is that cup of coffee
sometimes i'm thinking about it as i'm
going to bed the night before and i
probably have a second a second cup most
days um am i doing something wrong here
am i overly caffeinating my brain am i
harming my sleep am i doing something
too unnatural to my normal rhythm
based on what you just said you're not
doing anything wrong and i would
actually recommend drink coffee which
sounds strange from someone like me
but when it comes to coffee
just like with drugs the dose and the
timing makes the poison
so first there are some wonderful health
associations with coffee um and that is
i think very strong evidence by the way
it has nothing to do with the caffeine
though
that the principal reason you get health
associations with a cup of coffee is
because the coffee bean contains most of
the antioxidants that people eat or
consume
because our diets are not particularly
enriched uh the way that we eat in this
modern era in antioxidants and it's left
to the coffee bean the humble coffee
bean to carry the weight of most
people's antioxidant needs
so
a cup of coffee or two cups of coffee or
even three cups of coffee in the morning
that's just fine try to cut yourself off
after about midday for most people and
here's the the reason why
firstly
coffee or caffeine has a half-life of
about five to six hours in other words
after about five to six hours fifty
percent of that caffeine is still in
your system which means that caffeine
has a quarter life of 10 to 12 hours
so if you have a cup of coffee at midday
it would be the equivalent of you
getting into bed at midnight and before
you turn the light out you swig a
quarter of a cup of coffee and you hope
for a good night of sleep and it's
probably not going to happen
but even if you're one of those people
who says you know look i can have an
espresso with dinner i fall asleep fine
and i stay asleep so no harm no foul
that's not quite true either because
a cup of coffee in the evening will
decrease the amount of deep sleep that
you get deep non-rem sleep by somewhere
between 20 to 30 percent
now for me to take away that amount of
deep sleep from you i would probably
have to age you by about 15 years
or you could just do it every night with
an espresso
so i think you know i
i want to be clear here i am
i'm just a scientist and i'm not here to
tell anyone how to live their life
that's not my job all i want to do is
you know give you the science behind
sleep and things like caffeine so that
people can make an informed choice you
know life is to be lived to a certain
degree yeah so when you meet the people
who are like oh you know if i have a cup
of coffee after 4 p.m i'm up all night
versus the guy that can have the double
espresso at 11 is that partly just how
they're wired i mean is that just their
physiology it is their physiology and in
fact it's their genes and we know these
genes there are several different genes
um and it's if you want to sort of get a
little bit nerdy it's called cytochrome
p450 and it determines the speed of
breakdown of decomposition essentially
of the caffeine in your system
now some people have a version of that
enzyme where they will break down the
caffeine very quickly
other people and unfortunately i'm one
of them have a version of that enzyme
where the caffeine metabolism is very
very slow so if i have a cup of coffee
at you know 9 a.m in the morning after
waking up at you know 6 30 or 7 in the
morning even that usually leads to me
not having a great night of sleep so
there are individual differences and we
understand the genetic basis of those
what about some of the habits of good
sleepers one of the things that i've
been trying to do for the last couple
years probably about two years now is i
try not to bring my phone in the bedroom
so i don't want the phone to be the last
thing that i look at when my head hits
the pillow and i don't want it to be the
first thing that i see when i wake up in
the morning that that's been pretty
helpful for me do you guys recommend
certain habits or or have you found that
certain people just have better habits
related to actually getting to that deep
sleep
yeah i think you mentioned a great one
here which is the phone you know the
invasion of technology into the bedroom
has been a harmful influence on our
sleep in the modern era
and in a way though you know that genie
is out the bottle and it's not going in
anytime soon so there's no point in me
necessarily saying you know it's got to
be a technology-free environment what i
would say though is
you've probably had that experience
where you know that you need to get up
for an early morning flight or there's
something that you have to do ultra
important the next morning you know that
that night of sleep is just not going to
be the best night and it's almost as
though if you've got to wake up at five
in the morning for your flight
you wake up at 4 58 before your alarm
yep and the reason is because the brain
stays in this very shallow form of sleep
it's not very restorative sleep and it's
a phenomenon that's called anticipatory
anxiety in other words you know
something is upcoming and the brain goes
into almost this threat detection state
because of the anxiety and your sleep is
shallow for understandable reasons i
mentioned this because having your phone
there is a kind of diet version of that
you know it's sort of anxiety light
l-i-t-e yeah for the next day because
you're you're right for most of us and
i've been guilty of this in the past
you know the first thing that we do when
we wake up in the morning is reach
across and we swipe right and we open up
the phone and we know that there is
waiting for us just a tsunami of anxiety
of emails social media it all comes
through yeah and what that does is that
it trains your brain to expect that type
of anxiety jag each and every morning
and so when you go to bed at night
you're not going to have that
restorative restful sleep the other
thing with technology by the way in the
evening is that it causes what's called
sleep procrastination it's a real thing
where you know you're perfectly tired
you could fall asleep but you have your
phone there and you think oh i should
just check facebook one last time and
i'm just going to order that thing on
amazon and you know oh you know dave
rubin i think he had this great section
i'm going to watch the
and all of a sudden it's 20 minutes
later and you do that each and every
night it's like compounding interest on
a loan and it can really degrade your
sleep so i would say the rule of thumb
if you want to try and hack that is you
can only use your phone in the bedroom
when you're standing up
and after about five minutes of doing
that you kind of as soon as you sit down
or you want to lie down that's the time
you've got to put the phone away yeah so
you mentioned the the compounding
interest part of this so so when people
are in those phases when you're just not
getting that good enough sleep you're
too busy
life's crazy anxiety whatever it might
be
what is the compounding effects of that
what are those effects
they are non-trivial um i think you know
we used to think of sleep as the third
pillar of good health alongside diet and
exercise now
in fact i was wrong when i used to say
that it is actually the foundation on
which those two other things sit that's
how essential it is and that's the
reason that we've now been finding
significant links and some of them
causal between short sleep duration and
things such as alzheimer's disease
depression cardiovascular disease
obesity stroke diabetes
numerous psychiatric conditions as well
and so i think what this tells us is
that sleep is
it's not really an optional lifestyle
luxury it is a non-negotiable biological
necessity
and if you use that sweet spot of seven
to nine hours a night there is an
unfortunate simple truth that the
shorter your sleep the shorter your life
short sleep predicts all cause mortality
it is the elixir of life you know it's
the sort of
it's the swiss army knife of health as
it were so as a as a scientist i'm sure
you're around scientists who would love
to figure out ways to make us operate at
higher levels with less sleep to be you
know quote-unquote more productive
whether that is true or not or i suppose
it would def depend on your definition
of productive but is there research in
that regard like you know if i could get
five more hours in a day just think
about all the things that i could do in
those five hours yeah and
the way that sleep science has
taught a lesson around this question is
a slightly different view
the the longer that you're awake so
firstly what we know is that after a
human being has been awake for about 20
or 21 hours straight you are as
cognitively impured as you would be if
you were legally drunk
you know which makes it surprises me
that
in the workplace not all workplaces but
commonly you know people are it's almost
this sort of sleep machismo attitude
sometimes where we're quite braggadocio
of how little sleep that we're getting
in and employers will sometimes co-opt
and encourage that kind of behavior from
their employees
and what's funny to me is that you know
no employer would say gosh i've got this
great team i'm working with they're
drunk all the time
you know but that's the situation when
your team is trying to survive on
insufficient sleep in a way
so rather than
answering your question in the sense of
can we although i do have several ideas
and desires to try to do what you're
saying which is can i compress sleep can
i kind of you know um what's the the
analogy would be can i create a zip file
for sleep can i you know shrink down the
time and we get everything that we need
in less time
i think that that's a foolhardy way of
doing it though because
when you are well slept you are just
much more effective and you are much
more efficient
so
to answer your question if you want to
get back those five hours of your day
don't think of sleep as a cost think of
sleep as an investment in tomorrow
because when you are well slept it's a
little bit like cooking why would you
try to boil a pot of water on medium
heat when you could do it in half the
time on high that is the consequence of
a good night of sleep and so sometimes
people say look i the reason i can't get
my seven to nine hours of sleep is that
i'm just so busy
and my response is sometimes well it may
be that you've got so much to do or so
much left to do because you're not well
slept and if you were well slept your
efficiency would increase and you
wouldn't have that much left on your
plate that's what the science is
actually teaching us
where do things like the pillow and the
mattress and the temperature and all
that kind of stuff fit into this because
i know just from youtube and online life
almost every ad these days is about a
new pillow that's going to fix all your
sleep problems or a new mattress or some
other you know uh if this this new sheet
has a special thing in it that will keep
you cool if you're hot or keep you hot
if you're cool or just some other
version of that there seems to be like a
real obsession with this now
yeah and and i don't mind the obsession
so much because in some ways it draws
attention to this you know sleepers
being the neglected stepsister in the
health conversation of today for the
past 10 20 years so that's okay but
there are you know there's a little bit
of snake oil out there for sure um we
don't have much data on the
effectiveness of pillows
mattresses um there is some data and
mattresses are tough because it's very
individualized based on your weight your
anatomical structure are you in pain in
terms of your back are you not are you
in pain for your neck
and i do like i mean the mattress is an
interesting
it's an interesting vehicle for sleep
researchers because when you think about
the car that you drive today
versus the car that you were driving
maybe you could have bought 20 years ago
from a technology standpoint they are
radically different nowadays your car is
packed full of sensors that measure just
about everything think about your
mattress though you know your mattress
today is much more similar to your
mattress of 20 years ago why is that the
case because we spend you know hopefully
seven to nine hours of sleep on our
mattress i very much hope that most
people don't spend that much time maybe
they spend two hours a day in their car
at maximum
so yeah we were happy to invest tens of
thousands of dollars in our car which we
spend less time in and we haven't got
there yet with mattresses so i think
mattresses have an untapped potential
and there are a number of companies now
that are doing this the final thing you
mentioned is temperature
this is definitely one of the things
that you can use to help manipulate your
sleep
it turns out that your brain and your
body need to drop their core temperature
by about two to three degrees fahrenheit
or about one degree celsius in order for
you to fall asleep and then stay asleep
soundly across the night and it's the
reason you will always find it easier to
fall asleep in a room that's too cold
than too hot
so what we've been finding is that if
you can use the mattress or just make
sure that your bedroom the ambient
temperature is set appropriately and
when i say appropriately for the average
adult it's somewhere between 65 to 67
degrees fahrenheit which i know sounds
cold but cold it must be if we can get
there usually better sleep unfolds yeah
i mean i'm completely with you on that
one we usually do probably like 68 which
is close close enough to that range i
mean it's pretty chilly in that room and
that that's the number because there's
nothing worse than waking up in the
middle of the night you're hot and
sweaty and like that yeah it's a
disaster and and that changes your sleep
cycles and the quality of your sleep as
well temperature all right let's talk
about marijuana where does marijuana fit
into the equation here uh because every
now and again not that often
i take basically like a puff or two once
or twice a week but it's really only at
night when i know i'm gonna fall asleep
soon so i got seinfeld on and i'm laying
on the couch and it's like one puff and
then once i feel the eyes go heavy i i
go to bed that's what i try to do every
now and again i pass out on the couch
but but what what do you think about
marijuana when it comes to sleep
i love it um seinfeld and a bit of
marijuana is the sort of the dave ruben
prescription for for good sleep there
might have been a glass of red wine in
there which i'll ask you about that one
too or you can just take it away from
there yeah but uh you'll have to send me
that t-shirt so um unfortunately uh it's
not great news when it comes to
marijuana but i want to separate thc
from cbd so cannabis um has a
composition of many different compounds
thc or tetrohydrocannabinol
is the psychoactive component of
cannabis that's the thing that gets
people high cbd is is different it is in
the non-psychoactive component
what we found is that cannabis use it
can speed the time with which you fall
asleep it's speeding up that so in other
words it takes you a shorter amount of
time to fall asleep but there are two
problems with cannabis use and sleep
firstly you develop a dependency and it
develops quite quickly and then when you
stop typically what you do is have
terrible rebound insomnia and you have
to jump back on the bandwagon again of
cannabis use
the second issue with thc is that it's
very good at disrupting and suppressing
your rem sleep your dream sleep and rem
sleep dream sleep is associated with
things such as your emotional and mental
health
things such as creativity and memory
benefits even
your lifespan is predicted by the amount
of rem sleep that you get it's also
critical for hormonal regulation
testosterone in men for example
so you really don't want to have
anything that disrupts your rem sleep
but thc will do that so i'm really not
you know
again i feel when it comes to coffee and
i'm gonna make things even worse for
myself when it comes to alcohol but
you know i'm a desperately unpopular
person by both nationality and
personality but when i start offering
these things i'm even less uh sort of um
interesting so
thc i would stay away from it cbd
however and we don't have enough data
yet nowhere near enough data to say
anything definitive but it looks
interesting i think what we can say
about cbd so far is that it at least
doesn't harm your sleep
there are some signs that it could help
your sleep and i think there are a
number of roots biological routes that
are tenable through which cbd could act
as a sleep promoter the first is that
cbd alters your body temperature and it
will produce a state of increased
hypothermia in other words it will help
cool you down the second thing is that
thc and there are some great studies now
demonstrating that it's a very strong
what we call anxiolytic meaning it makes
you feel less anxious if you can cool
the body down and you can switch the
body away from the fight or flight
branch of the nervous system in other
words the anxious branch of the nervous
system then you are well on your way to
better sleep so i can see why there are
at least two parsimonious reasons why
cbd could have a benefit do we have the
data yet where someone like me would
feel comfortable advocating that not
right now the only thing i would note is
that the evidence suggests cbd
is interesting in its curve and what i
mean by that is at low doses
cbd may actually be wake promoting and
force you awake and make your sleep
worse but at higher doses it seems to be
more soperific in that sense again we
don't have the data i am not a medical
doctor and none of this is prescriptive
advice it's just the science that we
have so far
but i would say that people should just
be a little bit mindful here again the
dose can make the poison when it comes
to sleep perhaps all right now the wine
part of this or we can answer this with
with all alcohol but wine we've all sat
at a table with someone who's drinking
wine and at some point they're basically
falling asleep at the table so how could
that not be good for sleep
yeah so alcohol um is not great for
sleep in three different ways firstly
alcohol isn't a class of drugs that we
call the sedatives
and sedation is not sleep but when you
have a couple of drinks in the evening
and you think well i fell asleep more
quickly you're mistaking sedation for
sleep and they're not the same thing if
i were to show you your electrical brain
wave activity when you've had a couple
of drinks in the evening during sleep
versus natural sleep they're not the
same thing
the second problem with alcohol is that
it fragments your sleep so you wake up
many more times throughout the night
now the problem here is that you will
typically not remember waking up so the
next morning you maybe you don't feel
restored or refreshed by your sleep but
you think well you know i fell asleep
quickly and i don't remember waking up
so it's not the alcohol but it
definitely will just litter your sleep
with these awakenings the final problem
with alcohol is that similar to thc but
through a very different mechanism
alcohol will also block your dream sleep
so
you know again i'm not trying to tell
anyone what they should do and you know
again life you know live life to a full
because i've heard that we're dead a
long time
so but you know if i were to give
politically incorrect advice you know if
it's just you and me now talking dave
and no one's just just us don't worry no
one's listening um the best advice i
would have is go to the pub in the
morning and that way the alcohol is out
of your system in the evening and
there's no worry at all but i would
never say that you know publicly on a
show got it so you go to the pub in the
morning so you can take that 3 p.m
although i guess it's not quite the nap
that you want you're getting more of the
other things right stick it out lust it
through and then you'll probably be
washed out by the evening so where does
diet fit into all of this because i
think we've all had different moments
where you know you eat a real rich heavy
meal and suddenly you're not necessarily
sleeping well you're maybe getting some
indigestion some heartburn that kind of
stuff that obviously doesn't help sleep
but i'm sure there's some other foods
that probably aid sleep and and foods
that probably harm sleep
it there's definitely a bi-directional
relationship for sure firstly what we
know is that eating to excess
in the evening and also eating a diet
that is high in sugar and low in fiber
both of those things have been
associated with significantly worse
sleep quantity and significantly worse
sleep quality
there is a bit of a myth though around
this you know you need to stop eating
after four hours or three hours what we
found is that you can go as close as 60
minutes before bed
and food doesn't seem to be a
significant disrupter of sleep now after
that once you get too close to sleep
then it does have a blast radius where
it can be detrimental to your sleep
there are certain different sort of food
types that may enhance sleep and this
comes on to sort of some of the
supplement world and i am very i'm a
hard-nosed scientist and again i don't
advocate for supplements but it's
interesting i've been doing a lot of
sort of reading and research around the
supplement space
you know and there's some fascinating
work things like tart cherry juice you
know i was thinking this is nonsense and
i was ready to read the papers and rip
them apart the scientific data
but paper after paper from some very
well respected scientists seemed to show
that it had a benefit
even kiwi fruit
seemed to have a benefit now why is this
the case for some of these studies i
don't think it's because there's
anything necessarily magical about them
it's that they are high in antioxidants
and what we found is that when you
administer antioxidants it has a
beneficial effect on sleep
and so when you're getting your
sufficient supply of those key
ingredients it seems to communicate a
signal to your brain for better sleep at
night
but overall i think when it comes to
diet you know staying away well a diet
that's high in sugar and low in fiber is
pretty much bad for just about anything
but it turns out sleep is part of that
problem too and it works both ways by
the way um if you're not getting
sufficient sleep you will gain more
weight
and there are a number of reasons for
this firstly your appetite regulating
hormones go in very bad directions when
you're not getting sufficient sleep so
you won't feel satisfied by what you're
eating and you'll want to eat more
because you're constantly hungry it's
basically the sleep deprivation induced
munchies and it's not just those
hormones coming back to cannabis
your body produces its own version of
those cannabinoids they're called
endocannabinoids
and most people have sort of had or
heard i'm sure you have not experienced
but when you have a little too much just
to smoke you get the munchies yeah and
you start just wanting to consume
everything because these cannabinoids
increase your appetite
they increase your desire to eat
well when you are under slept when
you're sleep deprived your body
increases its own production of
endocannabinoids that's part of the
reason why you start to feel so much
more hungry when you are sleep deprived
and why you will eat
somewhere between two to four hundred
extra calories each day when you're not
getting sufficient sleep wow that's
really interesting let's uh let's wrap
up with dreams because this will be my
fifth august off the grid and one of the
things that i've noticed is because i
try to work on exercise and diet and
sleeping better and just general digital
detox and relaxation i've noticed in the
four previous years that i've done this
that my dreams are more vivid during
that time maybe it's from being less
distracted or something so just broadly
what the hell is going on when we're
dreaming and and what can we do to i
suppose
maybe gain more insight from our dreams
or or something to that effect
yeah and actually i have a quick
question for you so when you're doing
the detox will your sleep schedule
change where you may start to go to bed
a little bit later and wake up a little
bit later no it'll i'll be going to bed
earlier usually because i'm not doing as
much during the day so you know for a
portion of this and perhaps right now as
this is being aired i'm hoping that i'm
on the beach and it's a nice bright
sunny day and i'm under a umbrella and
it's about 3 pm and i'm napping that
would be nice but then you know after a
day out on the beach by by 9 o'clock
there's a good chance i i could be
sleeping and then and then i'm still
regardless of when i go to sleep at
night i'm an early riser that definitely
is something new to me the last couple
years of my life where it's like and
maybe that's partly sunshine in la you
know it's sunny here usually at about 6
or 6 30 a.m and i'm usually just kind of
ready to go at that point but i probably
will get a significant amount more of
sleep in the course of these 30 days or
so
got it so firstly to stick a pin in the
daylight component
daylight will absolutely regulate your
sleep timing and you can use it on both
ends if you get too much light exposure
in the evening um then it will block a
hormone called melatonin which is
critical to signal to your brain it's
night time and it's time to sleep and so
when we have too much electric light or
we're using our computers at night it
stamps the brakes on melatonin and
that's why some people can struggle with
their sleep at night so try to dim down
half of the lights in your home in the
last hour before sleep and then you can
reverse engineer the trick in the
morning get lots of daylight you know la
is a great place to do that and it
enlivens you because it now sort of that
daylight will apply once again the
breaks on melatonin and it will help you
wake up
but coming back to dreams and the
function of dreams
dreams seem to rem sleep dreaming at
least seems to provide at least two
different benefits the first is
creativity what we found is that it's
during dream sleep when the brain takes
all of the information that it's been
learning and it starts to fuse it
together in creative and innovative ways
you know it's almost like informational
alchemy and so we go to sleep with the
pieces of the jigsaw but we wake up with
the puzzle complete
and that's one of the creative benefits
of sleep you know and there's a reason
that no one has ever told you to stay
awake on a problem
yeah
and there's a there's a very good
scientific basis for exactly that the
second interesting thing that we've
discovered and we've done quite a lot of
work in this area
is that rem sleep dreaming provides a
form of emotional first aid
and you can think of dreaming as
overnight therapy and rem sleep dreams
will take those difficult experiences
sometimes even traumatic experiences
that you've been having and it acts like
a nocturnal soothing bomb and it just
takes the sharp edges off those painful
difficult experiences so that you come
back the next day and they don't feel as
painful anymore
and so i think in that sense
dreaming you can think of it
as well it's not time that heals or
wounds it's time during dream sleep that
provides emotional convalescence
and those are the two functions that
we've been strongly associating with rem
sleep dreaming what about people that
don't remember their dreams i always
find it so odd because i really do
remember my dreams every now and again
i'll have a notepad by the side of my
bed and i'll scribble something down
that i want to remember for the next
morning something like that and i do
find that there are insights and i can
piece together something that maybe i
couldn't have otherwise what about
people that just have no memory of their
dreams you hear about that every now and
again
yeah it's not infrequent it's not
necessarily pathological it's not
something that you have to worry about
or go and see your doctor uh about we
don't truly understand why there
are those individual differences
we certainly know that they are present
but we also know that those people who
say look i just don't dream
it's not really that you don't dream as
you said it's that you don't remember
your dreams because if i bring those
people into my sleep center here at uh
at university california berkeley and we
can clearly see that they're going into
dream sleep and in fact if i go into the
bedroom well when they're in a rem sleep
phase and i wake them up and i say can
you just tell me what was going through
your mind before i woke you up they will
say it's the strangest thing i was
having a dream for the first time
it's just that when they wake up in the
morning that memory seems to evaporate
too quickly and it doesn't seem to be
committed to conscious memory
recollection
does it mean that that memory isn't
there at all i actually don't think that
that's true i think it's quite possible
that we remember much more of our
dreaming lives than we are consciously
aware of or that we have conscious
accessibility to but what we know from
brain science is that implicit memory
mem information that you're not
consciously aware of can still
profoundly change your decisions and
your actions and your behaviors so it
leads to a wacky hypothesis that in fact
you know much more of our waking life is
determined by our imprinted dream life
but we just don't have conscious access
to that dreaming and i say that because
you know i'm sure you've had that
experience too where you wake up and you
think
i was dreaming i know
what was that dream what was that
it's just gone and then two days later
you know you're getting into your car
and you see the keychain and it
instantly triggers the unlocking of the
memory of that dream
in other words that memory was always
there
it just you'd lost the ip address to go
and find it for conscious recollection
and if it's still there it could still
be changing your behavior
all right i said the dreams was the last
question but i'll give myself one bonus
question here which is do you have one
other tip or trick that i can
incorporate into this month so that i
come back as well rested and ready to go
and be back in the the crazy political
and cultural fight that i find myself in
11 months out of the year
you are a brave brave man knowing what
you do and i admire it greatly i am far
too thin skinned uh to be doing what you
do but you're definitely a wiser man so
let's not rush to judgment i probably in
the past 45 minutes just proven that to
be wrong as well but i will give you one
conventional tip and one unconventional
tip great the first conventional tip is
regularity if i could give you one
single thing to start doing go to bed at
the same time wake up at the same time
no matter whether it's the weekday or
the weekend and regularity is king
and the reason and because i don't think
people respond to rules that are just
barked at them they respond to the
reasons not the rules and the reason is
this that your brain has its own 24-hour
clock
and it responds best to
record sort of the recognition of
regularity so when it's getting
regularity it's going to anchor your
sleep and as i said improve the quantity
and the quality of that sleep so aim for
regularity no matter what day it is
in terms of an unconventional tip and
this may sound a little bit strange but
if you have a bad night of sleep and
everyone has them you know i am not
immune just because i know a little bit
about sleep i have got my big share of
bad nights and i've had my own bouts of
insomnia that i've battled and struggled
with
but after a bad night of sleep
people say what should i do and my
answer is do nothing
and what i mean by that is don't wake up
any later
don't drink any more coffee the next day
don't nap during that day and don't go
to bed any earlier than you would
otherwise
do nothing just stay the course and
repeat the same behavior because if you
wake up later
then you're not going to build up enough
of that sleep pressure that we spoke
about for you to fall asleep at your
normal time because you slept in later
and second if you go to bed too early
because you think last night was so bad
i should get to bed early
your body is not expecting to sleep at
that different time that new earlier
time so you're just going to lie in bed
awake tossing and turning and it's going
to be even worse
and then obviously caffeine and naps
we've spoken about too so the best
unconventional advice if you've had a
bad night of sleep is do nothing stick
to your routine
matt this was a little unconventional
for for my type of show but i thoroughly
enjoyed it this is exactly what i wanted
to do right before i went off the grid
and i hope that everyone watching is is
going to do a little bit of this in
august if no other month you know i
always do my off the grid thing in
august because i feel like it's end of
the summer if there's ever a time for
anyone to get their life in order that's
it and then hopefully yeah you can
incorporate it into those other 11
months i've really enjoyed talking to
you and i appreciate you doing the show
thank you so much for having me take
care and good luck with august thanks if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell